اسمي غير حكيم إذا كان يجب أن يكون ولماذا
كان يجب أن يكون عربيًا ، أنا
مدرس رائع ولست مدرسًا فقط ،
حديثي عن التعليم ، لذا فهمت
مرحبًا 400 شخص يعطون أو يأخذون
مخيفين حقًا وهذا أمر مخيف حقًا.
إنه أمر مخيف حقًا أن تأخذ
أنفاسًا عميقة حقًا أو أن أحاول أن أركز على
حواسي بشكل كبير في الوقت الحالي ، إنه أمر
مخيف حقًا حقًا ، يمكنك رؤية بعض
أجزاء الدماغ المسؤولة عن
الخوف وهي تتولى زمام
الأمور الآن  اندفاع الأدرينالين المجنون
وجسدي نوع ما على مستوى عالٍ حقًا
مما يجعلني أرغب في الاختباء
هنا ، لا تنظر إلي أي شخص ، لذلك في الواقع
لم أكن بحاجة إلى
الرعب ، هذا هو شعوري الداخلي
الآن إما بالنظر إلي وأريد ذلك
كن مجنونًا مثل مجنون لطيف وليس خوفًا مجنونًا سيئًا ،
فهناك الكثير ، إنه
شعور غريب حقًا أننا نشعر
أنه نظام نفسي وبيولوجي
يجعلنا مستعدين لأي تحد
يجعلنا نريده أو ذاك ولكن
هناك بالفعل فرق كبير لكننا '  سوف أذهب
مع الاستعداد ، إنه حقًا
قمة تطورية نفسية
للتطور البشري نشعر هنا
أننا لا نشهد فقط خطرًا أو نرى
شيئًا ما ولكن يمكننا أيضًا أن نتحدى ذلك
أجسادنا ، أذهاننا جاهزة لذلك ،
للأسف هذا أحد أسباب
فشلنا  إنه أحد الأسباب الكبيرة
لفشلنا في أي شيء نخافه
من اختبار قيادة نفشل فيه في
العشر مرات الأولى التي نفشل فيها وهذا
يعني أنه لا ينجح في معرفة سبب حدوث
ما تعلمون أنهم يرسلون الكثير من رسائل البريد الإلكتروني  في
العمل ، هل فاتني إحدى رسائل البريد الإلكتروني الفوضوية هذه ،
لكنني أقول إنك تعلم أن الخوف يجب أن يجعلك
تفشل ، فلا يجب أن أفشل عندما كنت في الصف السابع ،
كنت دائمًا أن الطلاب
يفشلون ويفشلون في كل شيء أفعله يعني
كل شيء في
الحياة الاجتماعية  الفشل ، كنت
الطفل المهووس الذي دائمًا ما يكون B
أكاديميًا لم أكن فقط الفشل ،
لقد كان ذلك الفشل الذي لم يرغب أي معلم
في التعامل معه ، صحيح أنني
أمضيت وقتي في الحياة في قراءة
كتب رائعة حقًا للأبطال العظماء الذين
ينقذون  يومًا بعد يوم
وفذ كبير من القوة أو الحكمة أو
النزاهة في بعض الأحيان ، خاصةً بهذه الطريقة
عندما كنت ألعب الألعاب ذات مرة ، كنت أكون
أولئك الأبطال الذين أنقذوا اليوم
خلال هذا الوقت خلال ألعاب ألمانيا هذه
يخشونني هي تلك الأداة للبقاء
التي علموني إياها  ما أفعله جعلني في
حالة تأهب وكان هذا الشيء هو الذي أخبرني للتو أنه
يجب عليّ أن أتجنب ذلك
الإثارة في اللعبة في
حياة المعركة التي كانت مخاوفي في الحياة في
مدرستي هي سبب فشلي كما تعتقد
أنك تعرف شيئًا تطوريًا كهذا من
شأنه أن يساعدك على معرفة أنه كان
العكس تمامًا إلى أن أصبحت
معلمة اللغة الإنجليزية في الصف السابع ، مدرس اللغة الإنجليزية للصف السابع
صغيرًا ، وكانت حالة تيفاني إلفيس قد
فعلتها قبل الأشياء بشكل مختلف معي
وأول حالة أثارت
فضولي  اسمحوا لي أن أحاول تخصيص
تجربتي التعليمية في الفصل الدراسي
بناءً على مهاراتي بناءً على قدراتي
وما أردت أن أتعلمه وقد قامت
بتكريس جهدي من أجل 30 شيئًا بسيطًا
يمكن أن يحدث فرقًا كبيرًا  في
حياة الطالب لم أفهم هذه
النقاط الأربع حتى شاهدت هذا الرجل في
محادثات TED ، إنه مدهش السير كين روبنسون
هو في الأساس مصدر إلهام بالنسبة لي وهو
نقطة إلهام لم أعطي
أي شيء في المدرسة حتى تحدث حتى
سمعت  وقمت بتضمين ما بداخلي ، علمت أن
هناك شيئًا خاطئًا سواء كان ذلك
صحيحًا أو في الأردن التعليم لا
يوصلنا إلى حيث نحتاج إلى تحدث
عن أشياء كثيرة وألهمني
كان هناك تلك الرابطة التي كنت أعرف ما أريد أن أفعله
في الحياة لذلك أنا  بدأت التجربة ، كنت
في نادي المحادثة باللغة الإنجليزية في
الجامعة الأردنية ،
وقد بدأت بالفعل في تجربة
الطلاب وأنا أعلم أن البعض منكم موجود هنا
، وأنا آسف لأنك اكتشفت
هذا الآن ولكنك كنت فئران اختبار حقوقي.
كنت أجرب وأردت أن
أعرف هل سبق لك أن حصلت على ذلك
الفصل ذلك الدرس الذي كرهته دائمًا ،
دعني أصفه لك ، لنفترض أن
الفصل الأخير في يوم الخميس بالنسبة لنا
وكان يوم الجمعة في الولايات المتحدة أردنا ذلك  عد إلى
المنزل ، لم نكن نريد ، ولهذا السبب كنت
أجرب محادثة اللغة الإنجليزية
، كان علي أن أعطي الطلاب
الذين لم يتم تعليقهم من أجل هذا بالطريقة التي
كانت مجانية ولا يدفعون
مقابل ذلك ، يجب أن أشركهم في ذلك.
يجب أن تجعلهم يتعلمون أن يكونوا
قادرين على ممارسة اللغة الإنجليزية في
بيئة مليئة بالحيوية وممتعة للغاية والعودة في
الأسبوع المقبل وهذا كثير لفعل ذلك من خلال تلك
التجربة بحثي الخاص
وكان الكثير من التطوير الذاتي للتطوير الذاتي
الذي قصدته من  التسويق لقد
تخرجت مع التسويق من التسويق
إلى القيادة إلى تطوير الموظفين
حتى شعرت بالراحة الكافية
لأتمكن من التدريس بشكل جيد ولكن لدي سنة واحدة
من الخبرة
بالمعنى التقليدي للتعليم حيث يمشي المعلم في توزيع
المعلومات
والطالب لحفظ فهمها
بمفردهم وإذا كان لديهم أي
أسئلة يمكنهم طرحها على والديهم
حول المعلم
لقد لاحظت شيئين لاحظتهما أن
الطلاب حقيقيون  أنا حقًا لم تشارك في
شيء آخر ، أي خطأ يرتكبه
الطالب يعاقب بوحشية وأعني
بوحشية في التعريف الكامل
لتلك الكلمة في امتحان الشهر الأول الخاص بك
لأن لدينا أول امتحان ثالث ثانٍ
ونهائي في امتحانك في الشهر الأول
لديك مرحلة 15 من  20 تعني أنك
لن تمنحهم أبدًا 95 في المائة أعلى
من 95 في المائة ، فمن المستحيل أن تكون
في تلك المرحلة متكتلًا
والمدرسة ولن تستيقظ أبدًا
فوق 95 ، دعنا نقول بسبب شيء ما يحدث
في الثانية  شهرًا حصلت على 10 من
10 - في هذه المرحلة من المستحيل بالنسبة
لك أن تتجاوز 85 وما إلى ذلك
وهكذا بحلول نهاية الفصل الدراسي ،
لا يريد الطالب أن يتعلم أننا لا
نتعلم أننا فقط
نحن ندفعهم حرفيًا إلى أسفل
المشروب التعليمي الذي كان مزحة واو
للطلاب وهذه الصورة
تذكرني حقًا بما كنت عليه قبل السيدة.
أخبرني والينغهام جميعًا ما يجب القيام به ،
هذا ما نقول لطلابنا القيام بذلك ،
افعل هذا ، لا أحد يتواصل مع هذا
الطالب ، لا أحد يخبره أنك تعلم أنك
تعلم ، دعني أساعدك في هذا الأمر ، فهذه هي الطريقة التي
ينبغي القيام بها ، جربها اليوم لا تفعل ذلك
'  لنعمل ، سنحاول مرة أخرى في المرة القادمة ،
حسنًا ، بصفتي مدرسًا ، قررت
أن أفعل شيئًا أردت استخدام
تجربتي في الحياة فشلي في المدرسة
كشيء لوضع الخطة لأنك
تعرف طرق التدريس التي كنت أرغب في القيام بها
في المقابل ، أردت أن
يكون الشهر الأول هو الخطوة الأولى بالنسبة لهم ليكتسبوا
لك معرفة العتبة الأولى لهم في
التعليم في صفي مع
الفضول ، حسنًا ،
وصلوا إلى الشهر الثاني ، ما الذي
يحدث لماذا ليس مفاجئًا ولا
يسقط الآن  هل يمكن لأي شخص
اكتشاف ذلك حتى تخبرني لماذا يرتفع ، لقد
فعلت شيئًا استخدمته في الألعاب التي كنت
ألعبها عندما كنت طفلاً كان لديه
نظام منك يبدأ
بصفر وكلما فعلت أشياء أكثر بعد ذلك
اكتسابها أساسية إذا كنت  لعبت من أي وقت مضى
لعبة آر بي جي ، فأنت تعلم ما تتحدث عنه ،
تعرف ما أتحدث
عنه وآمل أن يكون لدى معظمكم على ما يرام ،
لذلك يبدأ طلابي من الصفر
كلما زادت الطلبات وليس الواجبات المنزلية أو
المهام أو الاختبارات كلما زادت
الطلبات  أنهم يفعلون أكثر كلما
اكتسبوا المزيد من XP ، وكلما زادت
القوة ، فإن بعض المهام ستفتح
مهامًا جديدة لا يمكن أن تكون مفتوحة أبدًا ما
لم تفعل هذا الشيء الوحيد بهذه الطريقة
أحصلهم على الرغبة في معرفة أنني أجعلهم يرغبون
في القيام به  خطأ لأن ارتكاب هذا
الخطأ
سيمنحهم نقاط
خبرة إضافية ستجعلهم أكثر قوة ، وسنمنحهم مهارة إضافية ، هل
تجرب شيئًا ما لم ينجح ،
وما زلت هناك تنفذ هذا
ما أفعله مع نظامي التعليمي.
تبدأ مع صفر
XP خبرة قليلة جدًا تقريبًا المستوى
صفر أو لا شيء واحد حقًا باستثناء
المعلومات القديمة ، فكلما وصلنا إلى
المستوى الأول ، لم تعد نقاط XP الآن
تقوم بمهام كافية لكسب نقاط XP
وستحصل على مستوى  عندما تصل إلى
المستوى الأول ، فإنك تقوم بمهام أكثر تعقيدًا
ومكثفة وتصل إلى المستوى 2
ثم في النهاية تصل إلى
أنك على استعداد لمواجهة الرئيس ،
ويلاحظ الرئيس أن مهاراتي في الفوتوشوب هي مجرد
مهارة
للناس  يعني الرؤساء أن الرؤساء يعني
أن الطلاب يمكنهم التخلص منه أكاديميًا.
لا أريد أن أعرف
أي شخص أكاديميًا إذا كان
بإمكانك إنزالي أكاديميًا ، فأنت حامل
، فهذه هي نهايتك النهائية ، هذا
يعني أنه يمكنك التخلص منها.
إن إنزال رئيس في لعبة
ما ، فليس ذلك لأنك تنتهي من هذه اللعبة ، فهذه
لعبة تستغرق فصلًا دراسيًا ، وفي النهاية ،
تكون المباراة النهائية هي لعبة أخرى ، إنها ليست
اختبارًا للاختبار ، فهذا شيء ممتع
يفعله المعلمون ببعض المقاييس من أجل
هذه هي الطريقة التي أفعل بها ،
هذا ما يراه الطلاب هناك على
المستوى الحالي يذهبون إلى المستوى 2 جيدًا ،
واحد هو صفر مثل المستوى 2 ، وهؤلاء
المتلاعبون 8000 XP يجب عليهم كسبها
إذا لم يكسبوها.  للحصول على
هذا المستوى الذي يعادل الشاي  شير
إلى امتحان الشهر الأول ، هذه هي الطريقة التي يمكنني بها
الحفاظ على مقاييسي كمدرس
في المدرسة ، يذهب الطلاب إلى مستوى
أعلى والأكبر يرتفع
أعلى وأعلى ، وهذه هي الطريقة التي نحدد بها
درجته ، وهذه هي الطريقة التي أخبرهم بها
درجتك ، سيواصل أداء الامتحانات
لكنهم ليسوا مخيفين هم
لا يدفعونه للأسفل يريد أن يفعل ذلك
يريد أن يفعلها هو نظرة فاحصة ،
هذا هو الجزء السفلي مما
رأيناه للتو  لديهم المهام التي
يمكنهم إجراؤها في أهداف الدرس ، وهذا يستغرق
وقتًا أطول لشرحها ، لذا فأنا أبذل
قصارى جهدي مع الوقت الذي أمتلك فيه
أهداف الدرس ، فالأخضر هي المهام التي
يتعين عليهم القيام بها في الواقع لأداء المهام التي
ستأخذهم منها  مهارة واحدة إلى
أخرى من مهارة يحتاجون إلى
تعلمها إلى مهارة أخرى وعليهم
أن يحددوا كميًا جميع
المعلومات التي يجب عليهم تقديمها
للمستوى التالي لاجتياز هذا البحث وإعطاء
كل ما لديهم من تكلفة باهظة.
أنت تعلم أنه يعني هنا
تم إكمال المزيد من المهام ، كلما
اكتسبوا المزيد من XP ، زادت نقاط
الخبرة لديهم ، وكلما زاد تركيز مهاراتهم ، وكلما كان لديك
شخص ما ركز على مهاراته كثيرًا
من التحفيز ، يكون أكثر استعدادًا
لمواجهة ليس فقط المدرسة ولكن غدًا
مدرستنا يعلم نظامنا التعليمي
أن نكون خائفين من كل
حالة منفردة نتخيلها هذه الفكرة تجعل من
الممكن ألا نخاف فقط من
أننا خائفون ولكننا نستخدم
المجال لإيصالنا إلى مكان ما في الحياة ، شكرًا
لك